THAT IS "THE STORY" FOR
TONIGHT.
TUCKER CARLSON UP NEXT LIVE IN
D.C.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL RACE IS
EFFECTIVELY UNDERWAY AND HAS
BEEN SINCE THE MIDTERMS IN
NOVEMBER.
THE MOST FORMIDABLE CANDIDATES
HAVE NOT OFFICIALLY ANNOUNCED
YET.
THEY WANT TO BE FASHIONABLY
LATE TO THE PARTY.
IT'S OBVIOUS WHO THEY ARE.
THEY ARE LINING UP DONORS,
GENNING UP PUBLICITY AND
TRYING TO BE IMPRESSIVE.
THE BIGGEST CONTENDER IN THE
GROUP IS BETO O'ROURKE.
HE NEARLY BEAT TED CRUZ IN A
SENATE RACE THIS FALL.
DEMOCRATS LOVE HIM FOR THAT.
AFFLUENT PROGRESSIVES ON THE
COAST LOVE HIM BEST.
HE IS ONE OF THEM.
IN THE BETTING MARKETS,
O'ROURKE IS THE FAVORITE TO
WIN THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
TWO YEARS FROM NOW HE
PLAUSIBLY COULD BE IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
SO IT'S WORK TAKING BETO
O'ROURKE SERIOUSLY.
WHAT KIND OF PRESIDENT WOULD
HE BE?
AT THIS POINT WE CAN ONLY
GUESS.
WE KNOW LIKE MOST PEOPLE IN
HIS SOCIAL CLASS HE IS TOTALLY
AGAINST BORDER WALLS.
>> WE WILL FOUGHT WHEN
NECESSARY AGAINST A PRESIDENT
FOCUSED ON BUILDING WALLS.
>> NO WALL IS GOING TO SOLVE
LEGITIMATE SECURITY CONCERNS.
THEN PERHAPS YOU CAN BE
FORGIVEN THINKING THAT A WALL
WILL SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> WE IN EL PASO ARE ASHAMED
OF THIS NOW.
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS WHERE THE FOLKS IN
GERMANY LOOK BACK ON THE
BERLIN WALL OR THE UNITED
STATES LOOKS BACK ON THE
PROJECT TO INTERN JAPANESE
AMERICANS IN WORLD WAR II.
>> DID YOU HEAR THAT?
BERLIN WALL, BAD.
BORDER WALL, ALSO BAD.
INDEED, BAD, VERY MUCH LIKE
INTERNING THE JAPANESE DIRECT
WORLD WAR II WAS BAD.
ANOTHER RACIST ATTACK ON THE
ASIANS FROM THE F.D.R.
ADMINISTRATION.
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHATEVER.
WALLS ARE BAD.
OKAY?
SO FAR THAT HAS BEEN THE SUM
TOTAL OF WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
BETO O'ROURKE'S POLICY VIEWS.
THAT AND HE WENT TO THE
DENTIST RECENTLY.
WE KNOW BECAUSE HE PUT IT ON
INSTAGRAM.
THANKFULLY NOW WE KNOW EVEN
MORE.
O'ROURKE JUST DID A TWO-HOUR
LONG INTERVIEW WITH A REPORTER
FROM JEFF BEZOS' WASHINGTON
NEWSPAPER, "WASHINGTON POST,"
WHICH LIKE O'ROURKE HIMSELF IS
A FULL-TIME MOUTHPIECE FOR
GUILTY RICH PEOPLE.
O'ROURKE KNEW HE WAS SPEAKING
TO HIS OWN COMMUNITY SO HE
RELAXED LONG ENOUGH TO EXPLAIN
WHAT HE REALLY THINKS ABOUT
THINGS, INCLUDING BORDER
WALLS.
WALLS ARE BAD, O'ROURKE
EXPLAINED.
NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY INTERN
PERFECTLY DECENT JAPANESE
PEOPLE BUT BECAUSE THEY
LITERALLY COMMIT MURDER.
RATHER WE COMMIT MURDER WHEN
WE BUILD WALLS.
AS O'ROURKE PUT IT, IF YOU
CONSTRUCT A BARRIER ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, "YOU WILL
ENSURE DEATH.
YOU AND I AS AMERICANS HAVE
CAUSED THE DEATHS OF OTHERS
THROUGH THESE WALLS."
LET THAT SETTLE.
WHOA!
WE KILLED PEOPLE.
WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IT.
THAT IS PRETTY HEAVY.
HOW MANY PEOPLE DID WE KILL?
SHOULD WE TURN OURSELVES IN TO
THE AUTHORITIES OR PREPARE FOR
LIFE ON THE LAM?
DO WE NEED PASSPORTS?
EXTRA SECURITY?
DOES PARAGUAY HAVE EXTRADITION
TREATY?
SO MANY QUESTIONS.
BUT THE REAL QUESTION IS WHAT
THE HELL IS BETO O'ROURKE
TALKING ABOUT?
IT'S NOT LIKE HE IS PRETENDING
TO KNOW.
HE MAKES IT PERFECTLY CLEAR HE
HAS NO IDEA WHAT HE IS SAYING.
THAT IS OKAY.
HE IS NOT EMBARRASSED ABOUT
IT.
WHEN THE "WASHINGTON POST"
ASKED O'ROURKE WHAT HE WOULD
DO ABOUT ILLEGAL ALIENS
OVERSAYING THEIR VISAS, A HUGE
PART OF THE IMMIGRATION CRISIS
HE ANSWERED THIS WAY.
"I DON'T KNOW."
THANK YOU, MR. SPECOLI, PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEAT.
HE IS NOT IN DETAILS.
HE'S IN TO IDEAS.
BIG IDEAS.
IDEAS OF THE FUTURE.
SWEEPING PANORAMIC TRUTHS
ABOUT BEING, PERSONHOOD AND
NEW MODES OF AUTHENTIC
EXPRESS.
THE -- AUTHENTIC EXPRESSION.
HE IS BIGGER THAN THAT OF A
MICRO GUY.
HE IS A TRANSFORMER.
WHAT HE WANTS TO TRANSFORM
NEXT IS NOTHING LESS THAN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
STARTING WITH THE BELIEF THE
COUNTRY WAS FOUNDING ON.
THAT IS WHAT HE TOLD JEFF
BEZOS' NEWSPAPER.
DOES THIS STILL WORK, HE
ASKED?
"THIS" BEING AMERICA.
HE WASN'T SO SURE.
SO HE ASKED A QUESTION THAT
FUTURE HIS HISTORIANS WILL
RECOGNIZE AS A PIVOT POINT IN
THE LIFE OF THIS COUNTRY.
CAN AMERICA "STILL BE MANAGED
BY THE SAME PRINCIPLES THAT
WERE SET DOWN 230-PLUS YEARS
AGO?"
THAT IS NOT A SMALL QUESTION.
THE PRINCIPLES HE REFERS TO
WOULD INCLUDE "BILL OF RIGHTS"
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, FREEDOM OF
ASSEMBLY AND RIGHT TO
SELF-DEFENSE AND FAIR TRIAL.
DOES ANY OF THAT STILL MATTER?
OR ARE ALL OF THOSE OLD IDEAS,
STUMBLING BLOCKS PREVENTING
PEOPLE LIKE BETO, GOOD AND
BRILLIANT PEOPLE WHO WENT TO
COLUMBIA AND HAVE BEAUTIFUL
WEEKEND HOMES FROM GETTING THE
POWER THEY NEED TO TURN THE
PLACE TO A TRULY AWESOME
COUNTRY?
A COUNTRY WHERE THE
SKATEBOARDS OUTNUMBER
S.U.V.s, AND EVERYONE IS
THIN AND HAS QUALITY CHILD
CARE.
A NATION THAT VALUES HOT YOGA
ABOVE FOOTBALL.
PLACE WHERE INSENSITIVE
THOUGHTS ARE BANNED AND